while the impeachment inquiry dominates
national headlines 2020 Democratic
hopefuls are in Des Moines right now for
one of the most important events before
the Iowa caucuses 14 candidates will
take the stage tonight at the liberty
and justice celebration polls say that
senator Elizabeth Warren has a
five-point lead in Iowa CBS News special
correspondent Alex Wagner is co-host of
Showtime's the circus she is outside the
Wells Fargo Arena that's in downtown Des
Moines Alex always good to see you how's
the impeachment inquiry affecting the
voters there well Gail it doesn't have
quite the same impact here as it does in
Washington here in Iowa bread-and-butter
issues like health care and jobs those
still matter the most and tonight's
dinner is in a it's a moment for
candidates to show the power of their
message and the strength of their ground
game on the eve of one of Iowa's largest
political events of the season campaigns
are scrambling hey John this is Sidney
with Cory Booker's campaign the Liberty
injustice celebration is a chance for
Democratic candidates like Kamala Harris
and Cory Booker to define the narrative
and raise expectations it's where
then-senator Barack Obama's presidential
campaign was jolted to life in 2007
helping catapult him past Hillary
Clinton and putting him on a path toward
the nomination if they don't do well
here
and by doing well if they aren't in the
top two or three right it's over for
them
Matt Paul was Hillary Clinton's Iowa
Director for a 2016 presidential
campaign does impeachment matter at all
does it make any kind of impact among
the voting electorate in Iowa I don't
think it's going to outweigh the
importance of health care yeah on the
specific issues of co-pays premiums on
prescription drugs
that's what Iowans are dialed in on Iowa
polling expert and Seltzer says
impeachment animates the national
audience
but in her state the issue plays
differently when speaker Pelosi
announced that she was starting the
inquiry I thought I'm just going to keep
my ear to the ground and see what
happens here and it was strangely silent
and really I I have not heard that many
Iowans sort of start jumping up and down
on either side while the Democratic
field is big and volatile I can tell you
from here on the ground in Des Moines
that there is a lot of interest in
senator Elizabeth Warren and mayor Pete
Budaj and a lot of concern about the
prospects for the national frontrunner
Vice President Joe Biden gale yeah their
perspective is interesting to hear from
the Iowa voters there's a whole big
world outside of Washington but Alex
let's talk about Kamala Harris he I know
you know that so she's shaking up her
campaign we hear laying off some staff
members and shifting a lot of her
resources to Iowa what does that say to
you about her strategy Harris has money
problems there's a lack of perceived
enthusiasm she doesn't do that well in
national polling but the truth from the
Iowa polling is that she's a lot of
people's second and third choice and so
she could have a strong finish in the
Iowa caucus which will be critical to
continuing momentum for her campaign and
more importantly convincing donors that
they should give her campaign money we
are all in on Iowa Gale got it thank you
very much Alex